Joe Biden made waves yesterday by
promising free healthcare for illegal
aliens but Joe is just trying to keep up
with the rest of the 2020 Democratic
pack which is promising free everything
for everybody we will analyze the high
price of free stuff then the mailbag I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
old Uncle Joe is at it again the most
tried-and-true trick in the Democratic
playbook promised to give a bunch of
free stuff to everybody to buy their
votes he's just trying to keep up with
everybody else we will analyze his plan
and how it fits in with the free stuff
primary but first let's talk let's talk
about real value forget about free stuff
let's talk about value let's talk about
purple mattress you know you're looking
at me today you're you're thinking gosh
Michael you sound a little tired you
look a little you look like you didn't
sleep in your purple mattress last night
that's right because I was on the road
and I slept in a hotel and I nearly
cried myself to sleep because of how
much I love and appreciate my purple
mattress purple mattress is unlike any
mattress you've ever slept on it's not
quite an innerspring it's not quite a
memory foam it's this new technology it
is both firm and soft at the same time
how is that possible I can't tell you
I'm not a rocket scientist but a rocket
scientist developed this product and it
is the best sleep of my life
sweet little ELISA loves it I think she
married me for the purple mattress it is
it also sleeps pretty cool so this is
another thing sometimes in the summer
you get really hot you throw the sheets
around some have the purple mattress
sleeps nice and cool it'll just give you
the best sleep 100 night risk-free trial
if you're not fully satisfied return it
for a full refund backed by a 10-year
warranty free shipping and returns free
in-home set up an old mattress removal
you're gonna love purple right now my
listeners will get a free purple pillow
with the purchase of a mattress that's
in addition to a lot of other free
goodies site-wide just text right now
stop what you're doing stop it
text Knolls KO wles two eight four eight
eight eight that's the only way to get
this free pillow text Knolls KO wles to
eight four eight eight eight KO wles to
eight four eight eight eight message and
data rates may apply alright Joe Biden
he's feeling good he's gotta believe at
the latest measure a thirty two point
lead over the next strongest Democrat in
the race Bernie Sanders and so now he's
going back to that old tried-and-true
Democrat playbook promised everything
for free to everybody how's it going
do it free healthcare for illegal aliens
[Music]
I think that anyone who is in a
situation where they're in need of
health care regardless of whether
they're documented or undocumented we
have an obligation to see that they're
careful that's why I think we need more
clinics around the country and this idea
that undocumented and by the way a
significant portion on dr. undocumented
folks in this country are there because
they've overstayed their visas it's not
people breaking down gates coming across
the border and so I look the biggest
thing we got to do in this is is just
tone down the rhetoric we know why it's
happening
this creates fear and concerns why are
you job in tough shape because of that
that the event he describes it very
graphic unflattering terms that other so
rambling Joe made about five points or
he started and tried to make about five
points and he didn't make any of them
maybe this is where President Trump is
going with his sleepy Joe nickname I
thought that wasn't a great nickname but
the image the President Trump is trying
to give is that Joe Biden is tired he's
exhausted he's senile he's doddering
he's he's just a little out of it and
that is the feeling that you get from
that answer so just to begin Joe Biden
is talk about how talking about how we
blame illegal immigrants for taking our
jobs nobody is blaming anyone for taking
their job right now because unemployment
is at a forty nine year low there are
many many many more jobs to be filled in
this country than people who are looking
to fill them so nobody is blaming
anybody about taking anybody's job this
is a big difference I understand why Joe
Biden got confused here because the
unemployment rate during the obama-biden
years was 9% upwards of 10 percent that
unemployment rate actually didn't drop
below nine percent until 2011 almost
until the end of the first term but
right now employment is doing well the
question of illegal immigration
is not primarily one of employment there
are many other factors here factors that
pertain to our social services factors
that pertain to our culture factors that
pertain to the rule of law now Joe Biden
does make a cogent point here a nearly
cogent point he says most illegal aliens
are visa overstays now this would have
been a cogent point about two years ago
right now though that isn't probably
true right now we have about 3,000
illegal aliens per day poring over the
border with Mexico so how many visa
overstays do we have on average we have
about 700,000 visa overstays per year
but if we have a million illegal aliens
coming in if you annualize the number of
people who are coming in per day you
actually have more people crossing the
southern border illegally but let's say
that Joe Biden's point were true let's
say that the majority of illegal aliens
in this country didn't cross the
southern border but they were visa
overstays so what is that supposed to be
comforting don't worry our completely
porous immigration system that makes a
mockery of the rule of law and American
citizenship don't worry it's people
taking airplanes not crossing the Rio
Grande how is that supposed to make me
feel better it still means that our
federal legislators have failed a basic
task they've failed to enforce our
national borders the things that make up
our nation the things that define our
nation not very comforting now on a
broader point Joe Biden is right he's
right
not just about the future he's right
about now he says illegal aliens should
have access to medical care they do they
have free medical care we currently
provide medical care to illegal aliens
at hospitals if you show up at a
hospital regardless of your immigration
status regardless of your citizenship
regardless of whatever you will be
treated as well we should I the the left
wants to portray conservatives as these
heartless people who want illegal aliens
died in the street like where mr. burns
you know counting our dollar bills and
and not caring about anybody else what
are you talking about we're the most
generous country in the world and yes we
want people who are here to have medical
care we don't want people to be turned
away because they don't have enough
money or because they're not citizens
what sort of society would we be if we
did that the area when it gets
complicated is that Democrats are
pushing for socialist health care now so
it's not just you show up last-ditch you
show up to the emergency room and we
take care of you because we're a good
country
now it's socialist medicine a much
bigger system a much more expensive
system and a system with much less
patient choice so let's see how quickly
that gets out of hand all of the already
you hear Joe Biden said listen we can't
just provide free socialist health care
for American citizens we've got to
provide it for the 20 million illegal
aliens in the country yeah well that
gets pretty expensive country only has
what 300 320 million people you've
increased that by 1020 million people
that's significant and then once you
grant the premise that the government
won't just subsidize health care won't
just pay for a little bit of health care
like Medicare but will actually run the
health care system what is the limiting
principle that is going to rein in costs
and rein in services this is why the
government shouldn't negotiate with
public sector unions this is why public
sector unions don't make any sense
because you have the government
negotiating with itself you have the
government negotiating with the people
who make donations to politicians and
the people who go and vote for
politicians and who then work for the
government so there's no incentive to
rein in costs same thing with socialist
health care if what you're dealing in is
votes if if the thing that you are most
covetous of is votes then you are going
to try to buy off as many of those as
possible and by the way once democrats
take power once you get a democrat
president with a democrat Senate and a
democrat house you are going to see mass
amnesty for illegal aliens why
because they'll they'll legalize
instantly 10 million votes we know
statistically recent immigrants legal
and illegal from Latin America which is
where the vast majority of these
immigrants that we're talking about
dreamers and crossing the southern
border or from they overwhelmingly vote
for Democrats they are eight times as
likely in some cases to identify with
Democrats as with Republicans and this
doesn't go away after one generation
this persists throughout multiple
generations and so Joe Biden is using an
old tried-and-true trick saying yeah
we're going to give a lot of free stuff
away to everybody
the taxpayers aren't going to attack me
for it and because they're they're just
not paying enough attention and we're
going to overwhelm them and we're going
to turn California blue and we're gonna
turn Texas blue and then I'm going to
pander to this group of people that I'm
about to make legal this is more
evidence of what this election is
turning into which is the Democrats free
stuff election it's the free stuff
primary I could use another term it's a
little saltier but if free stuff is what
it is it's what it all boils down to
Democrats are currently promising a
whole host of free programs not just the
typical hey you vote for me and I'll
give you a little something extra we are
talking about radically transforming our
system of government and our economy
we'll go through those programs in a
second but first I'm so happy right now
to be in Missouri because in Missouri is
a Constitutional Carry state I should
have I should have come armed if I did I
would use my We the People holster We
the People holsters offers custom-made
holsters all made in the USA this is
really important people don't care about
buying american-made goods anymore it
matters you want to support American
workers you want to support American
ingenuity they designed their own
holsters in-house means they don't use
any third-party molds for their holsters
instead they design every mold unique in
Las Vegas in order to best fit each and
every firearm perfectly constantly
update designs new designs every month
they have their own 3d design team which
measures every micro millimeter of their
guns to ensure the perfect fit
you rely on your gun you invest time in
your firearms you invest money in your
firearms don't buy some low-quality
holster We the People holsters are the
best I've ever seen you can easily
adjust both the can't and ride of your
holster so that it will fit comfortably
and securely at all times and you'll be
able to place the holster on your back
and see the can't and ride for easy
access they're just fabulous they come
with a lifetime guarantee every holster
ships for free if it's not a perfect fit
send it back for a refund
right now listeners to the Michal
Knowles show can go to We the People
holsters dot-com / Knowles KO wles
and enter promo code Knowles at checkout
to get $10 off your first holster that
is as low as 37 bucks shipping is free
an additional 10 bucks off using my
promo code I'm giving you money I'm
giving you holsters come on don't be
foolish go to we'd the people holsters
comm / knowles and enter promo code
knowles a check out for $10 off that's
pretty good that's that's close to free
but what the democrats are offering is
the free stuff primary so first they're
offering free childcare parents should
no longer take care of their children
the government is going to come in and
take care of your children
we don't want parents you know
instilling any of those crazy ideas like
religion and traditional values in their
kids no we need the government to come
in and raise your kids for you
so elizabeth warren is now calling for
free child care child care by the way
can sometimes cost about as much as
college tuition in state of
massachusetts right now where liz warren
is from well I guess she's from some
Indian tribes somewhere on the Great
Plains but where she's currently living
in Massachusetts he sometimes childcare
can cost up to thirty four thousand
dollars per year to enroll both an
infant and a toddler in daycare
now Massachusetts is particularly
expensive but it's not the only
expensive place for child care I'm from
New York child care is extremely
expensive California child care is
extremely expensive so if we're now
going to offer this as a new entitlement
program to everybody in the country how
much money is that going to cost how
much is that going to cost you in your
taxes next thing you're giving away for
free is free college
Burnie is now offering free Community
College and four-year public
universities for families earning less
than $125,000 per year Elizabeth Warren
Leah Wafaa is doing him one better
she's saying forget about free Community
College and free you know a four-year
public College she's saying that
regardless of where you go to college
the federal government will pay off up
to fifty thousand dollars worth of loans
for any graduate earning less than a
hundred thousand dollars a year what did
you earn in your first job out of
college unless you were working at an
investment bank or in consulting
something tells me your first job out of
college you weren't making $100,000 a
year I certainly wasn't so now Liz
Warren is going in and essentially
saying to every every single college
graduate hey we'll give you $50,000 for
free sure hope you vote for me and she
has to be more radical than Bernie
because she's polling a lot lower than
Bernie and as we have been predicting
for months this primary is just to see
who can be the farthest left candidate
who can be the most extreme radical
candidate who can give away the most
stuff for free
so then Kamala Harris comes in Cory
Booker comes in kirsten gillibrand all
in the Senate they co-sponsor the debt
free college act I always tell you about
the free part they always tell you how
some people are gonna get stuff for free
they don't tell you about who's gonna
pay for it you can't get something from
nothing you have to get something from
somewhere so somebody is gonna pay for
that that's gonna be me and you
to their credit I hate to be nice to the
guy because he's a huge jerk but Peabody
judge actually has come out against this
idea Amy Klobuchar also has come out
against this there's at least some
modicum of almost sensibility going on
in the Democrat primary only those two
guys only on that one issue next thing
they're going to give away
they're giving away day care they're
giving away college
now they'll just they'll go for broke
they'll just give away free money so the
entire Democrat field right now is
offering free money to everybody other
than John Hickenlooper
John who John who the guy who is never
going to win the Democrat nomination
yeah that guy and tulsi gabbard
congresswoman from Hawaii I think other
than them the entire Democratic field
has endorsed a universal basic income
for Americans and not just a universal
basic income in some great philosophical
way they're endorsing a universal basic
income for Americans who are quote
unable or unwilling to work I understand
the philosophical and the policy
argument for a robust social safety net
even for a universal basic income to
people who really can't provide for
themselves what they all support is the
ubi for people who are unwilling to work
and how are they all endorsed it they've
all endorsed it in the green New Deal so
if you bring this up to them they'll say
no I was supporting that environmental
legislation
well the environmental aspects of the
green New Deal are actually a relatively
small portion of the law the much more
significant portions of the law are
completely uh pending our health care
system fully socialist health care
redistribution of wealth and yes a
universal basic income for all Americans
so that's the free money part but
believe it or not the free money part
isn't even the most radical historically
speaking there are now Democrats who are
supporting reparations for the
great-great great-great grandchildren of
black slaves in the United States just a
cash payment a transfer of wealth from
who I don't maybe from the great-great
great-great grandchildren of
slaveholders but there weren't that many
slaveholders and who knows where their
descendants are is it going to be a
transfer from just white people what one
of the earliest slave owners in the
Americas was black oh is it good are
they going to decide it based on race or
gender
lineage or immigration status I don't
know probably they'll just take it from
the federal government they'll take it
from all of our taxes now lest you think
that reparations for slavery is some
radical crazy fringe idea do you know
which Democrats in the 20/20 field are
endorsing reparations all of them every
single one beta or Roark was sort of a
holdout and now he's endorsed it to
every single Democrat running for
president has endorsed reparations for
slavery so now a childcare college free
money free money but only if you're
black so free extra money but only if
you're the descendant of African slaves
then there's free housing you could what
are you gonna do with all that money you
got up you got to store it all somewhere
so the government's going to give you a
free house Elizabeth Warren Kirsten
Gillibrand and Kamala Harris all
offering mortgage assistance to people
direct payments mortgage assistance free
housing and then the most important one
of all the the great fever dream of the
left for the last hundred years free
health care they've wanted a federal
health care entitlement for all
Americans for a hundred years they're
calling it Medicare for all it's not
Medicare for all
it doesn't resemble Medicare very much
at all Medicare is a federal funded
health care program so you have your own
doctor you're using private programs
private clinics private insurance
whatever and the government is paying
for it Medicare for all
would eliminate those things medicare
for all would be single-payer run down
just between you and the government the
government is deciding prices the
government is deciding quality of care
the government is deciding who gets what
we've seen how terrible this can go in
the United Kingdom there were those two
poor little babies charlie guard and
baby alfie these two babies had
illnesses their parents wanted to take
them out of the hospitals and get them
treatment elsewhere and this
government-run hostile
said no your baby belongs to us the Pope
asked he said please bring the babies
here to the hospitals at the Vatican and
the UK health care system said no the
babies belong to us President Trump said
bring the babies to the United States
what are the UK government's say no the
babies belong to us because the
government big enough to give you
everything you want is big enough to
take away everything that you have and
so all of these presidential candidates
for the Democrats are promising free
health care and Medicare for all why are
they using the phrase Medicare for all
it's because Medicare is very popular
among old people senior citizens really
like Medicare and so they're trying to
use that phrase to sell it to everybody
but it is just a lie it would take over
one-sixth of the economy take away
choice and put very serious and and
every day daily life and death decisions
in the hands of the government now
ironically this is sometimes I think the
Democrats are just trolling us sometimes
I think they're in on the joke and they
just want to see us react ironically you
saw they want to give you child care
free money reparations housing college
medical insurance they want to give you
all of that
the only thing under their proposals
that you don't get for free is your own
money here's Joe Biden explaining you
know people say well Joe how you do all
this well guess what first thing I do is
gonna repeal this Trump tax cut I'm not
a joke so Joe Biden you gotta love him
sometimes he's accidentally honest he
gives away the whole game here all of
this free stuff the Democrats are
promising isn't about generosity or
charity it's about control he's saying
I'm gonna give you all this free stuff
I'm gonna give you this free thing and
this free thing and this free thing and
people ask me how I'm gonna pay for all
that free stuff and I tell him I'm gonna
take away more of your money wait a
minute oh whoops did I say that yeah I'm
gonna give you all this free Speirs what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna give you a ton of
free stuff and then
robbed you and I'm gonna take all your
money away or and I really generous
don't you want to vote for me it shows
you that the left it's it's like that
controlling parent that controlling
parent you have you know maybe it's a
really nice mother or grandmother I
guess could be a father they send you
money you go off you're living on your
own you and they send you money there
right you check hey go buy yourself
something nice
hey I'll pay for part of your apartment
I live in LA where every single person
is financially dependent on their
parents cuz none of them make any money
or really work at all and so say I'll
pay part of your rent I'll pay your your
car payment I'll pay your car insurance
but you know I sure would like it if
you'd come home for this holiday you're
not gonna come home I mean come on we're
doing all that nice stuff for you and
you're not gonna do me a little sign
ever ask for anything come on
I pay your rent you got a come on I I
did you a favor you're gonna you're
gonna come and listen to me now it's
it's about control people can give money
away in charity and in love and they can
also give money away so they get some
control over how you behave and that's
what the left is doing let's say for
instance that Joe I don't think the
numbers work for Joe Biden namely
because just the green New Deal costs 93
trillion dollars and you're not going to
be able to pay off 93 trillion dollars
by repealing president Trump's and
modest tax cuts from 2018 but let's say
the numbers did work let's say the
magical Democrat math did work and so
the government is going to pay for
everything that you they're promising
you for free by taking away exactly that
same amount in your taxes why do we want
the government to do that at all if it's
a wash if Joe Biden is saying I'm gonna
just pay for it by taking away your
money in taxes wouldn't you rather have
the choice wouldn't you rather pay for
your own college and your own housing
and your own health care and your own
child care wouldn't you rather pay it's
gonna cost you the same amount of money
wouldn't you rather it's actually gonna
cost you less money to do it yourself
because there's not that government over
and waste fraud and abuse but if it's
going to be a wash if somebody's got to
pay in the end if the bill eventually
comes do you would want the money
yourself there is no such thing as a
free lunch and you look I hate the
modern health care system it's awful
it's impossible to make appointments the
costs are very hidden unless unless you
have something like an HSA you basically
never see the prices of doctor visits
and tests and things like that
even so and even though our system is
very expensive you will never believe
how expensive healthcare gets when it's
free you will never believe how
expensive childcare gets when it's free
you will never believe how expensive
health care yes how much schooling
tuition housing ubi
money reparations it's so much more
expensive when the left-wing tells us
that it's all free that's the that's the
primary that we're dealing with right
now and then there's poor Eric's wall
well he didn't get the message that
everyone moved on to free stuff so he is
still stuck on the Muller Report he's a
little bit slow but I guess I'm a little
bit slow then too because Eric's wall
well is me and I am Eric's wall well and
you are me and I am the walrus goo goo
goo joob we'll get to that in a second
plus the mailbag but first I've got to
say goodbye to Facebook and YouTube I'm
here right now at the Missouri State
Capitol we were previously in this
beautiful office of state senator Eric
Burleson a tremendous guy has been so
hospitable today and then the minute I
went to broadcast this podcast the
entire internet in the capital went down
so I'm now in the bunker here
broadcasting from Missouri got to speak
here today on the importance of liberal
education and free speech on campuses
I'm gonna be going to Philly tomorrow to
go to my friend Matt Walsh's pro-life
rally at that Planned Parenthood there
in Philly if that Punk state
representative Brian Sims wants to show
up and take on somebody his own size
he's more than welcome to do that but
he's a coward who would rather stalk
little underage girls and elderly women
so I expect I won't see him maybe I'll
see you out there tomorrow if you're in
Philly come on out to the rally it
should be a good time we got a lot more
with the mailbag go to daily wire com
subscribe 10 bucks a month hundred
dollars for an annual members
chef's you get all the shows you get
everything you get the leftist ears
tumblr and you're going to need it
tomorrow go to daily wire comm we'll be
right back
poor Eric's wall well he didn't get the
message that it's all just about free
stuff so now he's focusing on the Muller
report still he tweeted out one of the
stupidest tweets I've ever read and do
you realize what that says do you know
how many thousands of stupid tweets I
read every single day it's practically
my job and yet this one ranks at least
in the top ten this is what he wrote
quote remember that time Pearl Harbor
was bombed and FDR called the Emperor of
Japan or the time the twin towers were
struck and bush
ringed Osama bin Laden ringed I don't
whatever no I don't either so why did
Donald Trump call Putin after the Muller
report was released
hashtag commander-in-chief before I
begin to take this tweet apart I would
just like to personally apologize for
the tweet because unfortunately I am
Eric's wall well and you are Eric's wall
well and we are the walrus goo goo goo
joob and therefore we all wrote that
tweet but if I were in Eric's wall well
I I would be able to eviscerate it
because how stupid first of all just as
a general rule don't compare anything to
9/11 it astounds me that politicians
still make this extraordinarily basic
mistake when has a politician ever
compared anything to 9/11 and it turned
out well for him ever no no never once
because on September 11th 3,000 American
civilians were killed by terrorists who
hijacked airplanes and in the Muller
report a special counsel discovered that
the President of the United States
didn't collude with Russia that's why
they're different
you see when Pearl Harbor was bombed
kamikaze Japanese pilots took out our
fleet in Hawaii
killed lots of American servicemen and
in the Muller report a lawyer figured
out that Donald Trump didn't collude
with the Russians so there I could see
how you'd get confused but they're
actually different things what Eric's
wall well is doing here because he's
kind of invested all his eggs in this
basket of Donald Trump colluded with the
Russians and so even though the molar
report very clearly says that Donald
Trump did not collude with the Russians
it exonerates him on charges of criminal
conspiracy or committing any crime with
the Russians nevertheless he's got a
double down on it and then this way he's
pretty smart this shows you the
narrative I've read the Muller report
right well I've read 200 pages of
whatever are the important pages some of
you very likely have read the Moller
report we know that the special counsel
and the Attorney General exonerate
President Trump on the charge of
colluding with the Russians and yet I
bet if you polled the American people
today I bet most of them think Trump
colluded with the Russians because
that's the power of the narrative and so
now the Democrats are stuck between a
rock and a hard place they're stuck
between the reality they were really
hoping for this Muller report to convict
Trump of being some KGB spy turns out
that isn't what happened and so now
you've got all the people they misled
calling for impeachment but then broadly
you've got the American people who
really don't want impeachment and Nancy
Pelosi has to answer at at both sides of
her mouth and I said the president is
goading us into wants to go to sent to
impeachment because that he knows as a
do I that that that's a not a good thing
for the colonel maybe he knows that but
he knows that I think that let's put it
that way
they knows that I think that but the
point is is that every single day
whether it's obstruction obstruction
obstruction obstruction of having people
come to the table with facts ignoring
subpoenas and the rest every single day
the president is making a case he's met
he's becoming self impeachable in terms
of some of the things that he
self impeachable what is self
impeachable he's impeaching himself
I don't it's she is just so lost here I
mean she's so lost she's doing something
that politicians have to do which is
just babble senselessly give an answer
that isn't an answer sometimes when you
ask a politician a tough question they
don't have an answer they'll say listen
I think it's very very important I mean
this very seriously and sincerely it's
very important that we look into that so
I don't want to actually do anything but
they have to seem like they care and and
so Nancy Pelosi here is she's talking
like she's really serious but she knows
she can't impeach him why because
Americans don't want to impeach Trump
the latest polling shows only 29 percent
of Americans want to impeach Trump
however the majority of Democrats still
want to impeach Trump and she needs to
hold a fractious House caucus together
so when she's asked this question she
can only babble nonsense it reminds me
of when you're in class and the teacher
asks you hey what do you think of this
chapter of the book and you haven't read
the book and so you just start saying
mealy-mouthed nothing because well if
you're asking me about impeachment I
mean really I could impeach I guess or I
mean really when you really think about
it he's sort of self impeaching himself
I think right is that right can I go to
the bathroom please so what is the
Democrats message going into this
election they're giving two answers
simultaneously did Donald Trump commit a
crime or not
sois well is saying he did the mother
report says he didn't now if he did
commit a crime what crime did he commit
the Muller report says he didn't collude
with the Russians collusion isn't even a
crime now if he did commit a crime
whatever magical crime they're gonna
come up with then why won't Nancy Pelosi
impeach him if Nancy put the president
committing a crime they should impeach
him the Democrats have the house if
they're not going to impeach him then
why do they keep pushing the narrative
that he committed a crime it just makes
them look impotent or incompetent
some look weak if he didn't commit a
crime
and they're not going to impeach him
then what is wrong with Donald Trump the
economy's great yet peace abroad things
are going really well
wages are rising for the first time in a
long time now 27 77 an hour is the
average wage you've got way more job
openings than people to fill them so
what's the argument against Trump what
is your argument now there is an
argument against Trump everything is
going great and yet Trump's approval is
just between 46 and 50% Rasmussen puts
him at 50 it's a right leaning firm
Gallup puts him at 46
but even according to Gallup Donald
Trump is doing better than Barack Obama
at the same point in this presidency so
Trump's poll numbers are better than
Obama's poll numbers however you've got
to remember the Obama years were
terrible they were awful on the economy
at 10 percent unemployment things were
dreadful during the Obama years right
now everything is going great I mean I
not only do I not remember when things
were going so well in this country
during my lifetime I don't remember when
things were going this well economically
and as a matter of foreign affairs ever
this may be when you when you just look
at the economy and foreign policy this
may be the best time in the history of
the United States and yet Trump's
numbers are only 46 to 50 percent now in
part this is due to a country that is
very politically divided and that has
been increasingly politically divided
over the last several decades
that's not Donald Trump's fault that's
been building for a long time also part
of this as many people find Trump
personally repulsive I don't I like
Donald Trump I'm from New York I get a
kick out of the guy but many people find
Donald Trump personally repulsive and I
get it I get why Barack Obama had the
opposite problem many people found Obama
personally likable but they hated his
policies I didn't I didn't find him
personally likeable at all but I and I
also hated his policies but with Trump
people love his policies and many of
them don't like him personally
this is the question that Democrats and
the free stuff primary have to ask if
their only chance is to make 2020 about
personality are people really gonna
trade prosperity for personality are
they gonna really trade their own
hard-earned money and their own economic
freedom for free stuff that costs more
money than the stuff they're getting if
people would trade all that prosperity
for personality then the question is
which personality is gonna be Trump
Kamala Harris no cory booker no but a
judge buddha judge maybe biden maybe but
if it really comes down to personality
are you gonna be able to beat the king
of reality TV seems unlikely let's get
to the mailbag before we gotta go we're
always running late
from timothy hey michael if you were to
have a chance to sit and talk with the
more prominent members of the Inklings
CS lewis JRR tolkien owen Barfield
etc and could ask them one question what
would it be one question I'd probably
ask them how heaven is because all those
guys are definitely in heaven right
there's no those guys were so important
I mean I'd love them all I don't I don't
like fantasy stuff but I still like
talking as a person as a thinker I think
that would be my question what is heaven
like because I would and I'm not I don't
mean that in a global way I want to know
their thoughts on theology and God and
religion they are all they all know the
answer now so that's probably what I
would ask them I that's what I ask them
every night that I read their books I'm
basically asking that question what's
heaven like from Michael Michael would
you be in favor of run off election so
that third parties actually have a shot
at election no I hate third parties I
hate them yes I know the Republican
Party is awful I know the Democrat Party
is awful third parties are worse they
can be spoilers if there is a runoff
you've got these these little parties
that come up and spring out of nowhere
you get an organized group of activists
and they they make a big dent I like
bigger institutions
I like slower institutions I am a
conservative I want evolution not
revolution
I want slow and gradual change there are
some radical changes that I would make
tomorrow if I were king or that I would
at least want to make but even those
radical changes that I want I would be
cautious about and I would make them
slowly and those big parties do have
real institutional heft and inertia to
them and they do have some coherence
especially these days in the old days
the parties didn't line up exactly with
political ideologies didn't line up with
leftism or with conservative thought now
much more so they do the Republican
Party more or less represents a
conservative view of the world
I know it's imperfect but all human
institutions are imperfect and so more
or less represents conservative thought
the Democratic Party also imperfect also
corrupt also all those things basically
represents the left-wing view of the
world those are coherent views there are
a lot of little parties that would
represent incoherent views there would
probably be a party of social liberal
fiscal conservatives I'm sure that party
would spring up and there are a lot of
people who would call themselves
socially liberal fiscally conservative
but that right that ideology doesn't
make any sense I get that people have
those preferences I would have called
myself that at different times but
doesn't make a lot of sense I like that
there is clarity between the two parties
and I like that especially these days
they're having an honest fight from
Aroon dear dr. Cerf effe I very much
enjoyed your take on tariffs along the
same lines what do you think of Tucker's
idea of banning self-driving trucks
we should bans should we ban certain
economic shifts if the resulting
cultural damage in this case mass
unemployment would be too much to bear
I'm not a Luddite so I don't take an
idolatrous view of free trade I think
there are negative consequences of free
trade particularly to culture
particularly of questions of mass
migration
particularly in questions of
surrendering some of your national
sovereignty because necessarily when you
engage in free trade in the 21st century
that usually doesn't mean bilateral
trade deals but that usually means is
you're engaging in these massive
international supranational
organizations the World Trade
Organization the IMF the European Union
whatever and when you engage in those
free trade systems and organizations you
by definition give away some of your
national sovereignty to a group that is
not accountable to your people so I'm
very aware of those risks and that's why
I think there are plenty of good reasons
to institute tariffs on certain
instances I don't think this is the case
for banning self-driving trucks I don't
think I question the premise that
self-driving trucks would cause mass
unemployment right now we have a booming
economy we have something like a million
more jobs open than we can fill so I
don't think we're gonna have mass
unemployment as a result of
technological innovation however it is
true technological innovation changes
culture there is a downside even to your
iPhone there is now my skeptical that
you can predict the negatives of certain
technological changes I'm skeptical that
anyone can predict the future but it is
certainly the case that massive rampant
technological change particularly when
it is married to globalization mass
migration free trade organizations when
it's married to all of this this can
have massive cultural change and if a
people wants to defend its culture
against even technological innovation
they should the trouble now for us in
the West is we don't believe in our
culture anymore we don't defend our
culture we don't participate in our
cultural institutions so it might be a
moot point because I I don't think that
anybody is going to trade their iPhone
for another extra couple nights at the
Lions Club I don't think anybody wants
to go back in time and nor should they
go back in time but I don't think people
are more protective of their culture
than they are of their stuff
and and that's a cultural problem in and
of itself from John hey Michael I
recently had a friend tell me they did
not keep the baby when she was younger
it has been close to 10 years since and
she still suffers from her past actions
she still cries about this and you can
tell it weighs on her I'm not sure what
I can say as she is looking to me for
comfort any thoughts or self-help books
that might help her with her struggles
thanks for your help I will tell you to
tell your friend what an ex mobster
turned born-again Catholic told me one
time in New York
Paul was a murderer even st. Paul was a
murderer people do very bad things and
abortion is a very bad thing and then
they can have a change of heart they can
repent what is repent me comes from the
word Metanoia it means to change your
mind you change your mind about
something at the time maybe you didn't
think abortion was a serious issue now
you realize it is life goes on
and you shouldn't wallow in self-pity
and wallow and regret and wallow in the
past you can't go back to the past the
devil wants you to go wallow in the past
and wallow in self-pity there's nothing
good about doing that you made a bad
decision in some cases a very bad
decision what are you doing now now you
move on you're sorry for it you pray for
that baby you move on with your life and
you live a good life
Paul was a murderer what if Paul just
decided after he saw Christ on the road
to Damascus he says oh but I
I can't spread the Christian religion I
can't become one of the greatest
evangelists in all of history because I
killed people I could never do anything
that we wouldn't have Christianity today
if that were the case
Paul was a murderer people don't commit
unique sins sin pervades the entire
world and and even that's suffering that
she's experiencing right now doesn't
have a moral quality suffering isn't
evil that your reaction to suffering
that determines if you're going to
respond in a good or a bad
way from Ivan dear Pedro Knowles no now
I'm Eric's wall well I used to be Pedro
now on the arocs wall well dear I'll
change that Eric's wall will since you
are of Italian descent what do you think
of Benito Mussolini and how much
distance Italy has put between itself in
the days of the fascist Kingdom of Italy
Italian politics is always terrible so
how much distance do they put they have
total distance because all of their
politicians are awful it's always been
awful this has been true since ancient
times Dante in the Divine Comedy refers
to Italy as a slave it refers to Italy
as a [ __ ] it we've had something like
45 governments in Italy since world war
two it's just completely unstable their
Italian politics is always awful and if
tradition is any predictor of the future
it's going to remain absolutely awful
all right we got a lot more to get to
but unfortunately we're out of time
that's our show I'm going to Philly
tomorrow so maybe I'll see you there
otherwise I'll see on Monday in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Knowles show see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dobkins and directed by Mike
joiner
executive producer Jeremy Borah senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stephens
edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is mixed by
Dylan case hair and makeup is by Joshua
alvera and our production assistant is
Nick Sheehan the Michael Noel's show is
a daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19 today on the Ben Shapiro show
Democrats in the Judiciary Committee
hold the Attorney General in contempt
and declare a constitutional crisis
that's today on the bench Shapiro show